all right are you afraid to do butt
stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
how often do you actually think about
sex i would say i think about it
like a couple times a day once you've
had sex it just
naturally crosses your mind i think not
like consistently but like
it'll pop in when i was a virgin
every single hour of every single day
after that
maybe once a day when did you lose your
virginity how was it
i actually lost it in october
of 2020. it was not the way i imagined
it because i come from religious family
i'm like i'm gonna wait
until i get married no it was like a
late night
a snap call i actually lost it pretty
early around 14
and it was by far not the best
experience i'll admit like it wasn't the
best obviously i didn't know what the
hell i was doing
i thought it was great it wasn't like
how you would think like porn is
yet it was still good though for a long
time
i actually thought that i had really
really young onset erectile dysfunction
i had like incredible anxiety when it
came to sex
and so every time there was an
opportunity to have sex it just
my body was not on the same page there
was actually one person in particular
who i'll never forget
but she was like laying on this bed and
she was like wow you have a naked woman
in front of you and you
and you can't get hard you know there
was just a flood of like all like
the feelings of like inadequacy and all
that i had been thinking was going to
happen negatively in my sex life
did happen in that moment do you get
emotionally attached to girls you have
sex with
for me it's based more on the
relationship that was built as opposed
to
how much sex we're having it's hard for
me to have sex without emotion
and i find myself like missing that
person after
i was like a late bloomer like nothing
in high school and then like after high
school
and in the college then like girl
started paying attention to me so i was
like
i could care less about being
emotionally attached it was like any
girl that i was
mostly attracted to i was like great
awesome you know
you maybe kind of suck as a person but
like oh well like we'll figure that out
later
i'm just happy to be here how much do
you
understand the female anatomy down there
can you name all the parts
right now down there isn't it just one
thing
i'm not a scientist or a major in
anatomy
i shouldn't even try this vagina good
start
okay okay i literally it's just the
vagina right that's
it so i know the clitoris well the [ __ ]
right
i know what the clitoris is
something major into something minor
labia
i don't think lips are i don't think
that's the real name yeah this is this
could be dumb but urethra
oh and the hood right i think i read
that somewhere
vulva that is it i mean how much stuff
could there be down there
how did i do cool i'm gonna watch
youtube videos after this now and just
can you describe how it feels to
ejaculate does it feel like peeing
i would say the only time it feels like
peeing is like when you're holding it
for a really long time
and like you're trying to get to the
bathroom and then finally you're just
like oh
i don't know it's like a build up and
then it just like
it's like a wave that just
you know but after you look you feel
gross like most of the time
i've like heard it from like most guys
like once i know like i feel gross
do you care if a girl is fully shaved
down there i don't think it's like my
place necessarily to be like you know
what actually can you change this for me
like i feel like that's kind of weird
i'm a big fan of just vaginas in general
however they're packaged i'm with it
i do prefer cleanly shaved but either
way is fine
yeah as long as they're hygienic for
sure
do you care if your partner doesn't
finish yes
everyone should care oh my goodness ah
this double standard frustrates me to no
end
i feel guilty if i don't when it comes
to sex
a large portion of that pleasure comes
from
seeing the other person's pleasure if i
am with them
and i'm like dating them like yes
actually like it's the first thing
at my list like she has to finish if
it's like a little hookup like i don't
it's amazing i don't care like i was
more worried about myself i'm not gonna
lie i
am like selfish as soon as it comes to
like hookups when i'm dating you like
i'm making sure that's all i really
really like care about
when i was in my my long-term serious
relationship i don't think she ever got
an orgasm at least for me so later in
the relationship i was just trying
so hard i was reading up on a lot of
stuff uh
just to see like what can i do to make
this happen
and it just never happened but it's a
huge hit to the ego
like oh man i wonder what that feels
like just because i've never i mean
i've never experienced that to be quite
honest have you ever questioned your
sexuality
absolutely 100 for a long time people
were like oh yeah
they would assume that i was gay et
cetera and for a while i just
hated that assumption but eventually i
decided to take the time to feel like
hey you know maybe
what if this is the case um and i think
i did my due diligence and like trying
to be honest with myself and recognize
what
was and was not interesting to me and
as such i think i came to a definitive
conclusion i'm definitely
team vagina for sure i knew very early
on that i liked
that i liked women i i had my first
girlfriend when i well my first
girlfriend when i was in
in first grade i had my first kiss with
a girl when i was in third
yeah no i was it's never something i
questioned yeah
i uh i grew up in a mexican household
so um so latinos uh
they're very be manly and be this and be
that and you know like
anything that doesn't involve whatever
typical man
is whatever that means um they were just
like no none of that
i've kissed a man or two
um i think that's maybe the extent of
experimentation
um have i thought about it maybe once or
twice
i lived in the midwest for all my life
and everybody over there is pretty
conservative
so growing up in that i was just known
to like
women for the most part it was a passing
thought at one point i did think about
it
especially after moving from home but
then i wouldn't feel that genuine
connection with another man
so i wouldn't act on it
have you ever been self-conscious about
your penis size
um no short answer
so the straight answer is yes because
there's an unfortunate stereotype
with people of my ethnicity that goes
around not saying that it's true or
false
but with that stereotype it gets to your
head just a little bit because
i mean you don't know if it's true or
false especially like
when i see myself naked and just like
okay
is this normal is this not normal i
don't know especially as a black male
you know there are a lot of expectations
that are very very very very lofty
you expect to have like a very large
penis
and you realize that you don't have a
very large penis
and so for a long time i think what was
what my a lot of my anxiety was rooted
in
was me being a disappointment um and
not meeting those expectations in real
time it's something that that gets a lot
of focus
when you go to the store or like and you
buy a pack of
of like boxers or something you're gonna
see a guy who's ripped
and he's packing like 10 to 12 down
there you know and it's like
what the hell like is that what we're
supposed to look like
when you enter like middle school you
start to watch porn
and like you see these guys that like in
the scenes and they're like
and then it just makes you think like
well i can't compete with that look at
me
are you afraid to drop to try butt stuff
yeah i don't want anyone coming near my
butt what
i think if i were the receiver yeah i'd
be afraid
and i i think i'd be afraid to even to
even
be the giver i don't know i've heard
some horror stories
i don't know i'm a little nervous i've
yeah i'm a little nervous but like i
think i got to try it at some point
i'm open to it kinda i'd say if i walked
down this door
and there was the opportunity to get
pegged i probably would decline like
and i don't i don't even know if i could
say why
because i don't i know i'm not gay it's
not a question of like my sexuality
i wouldn't say afraid i could be talked
into it there you go i could be talked
into in the right place in the right
time i could say yes
i ran into that topic one time and just
to you know
avoid double standards i gave it a try
and not for me
oh my god i did try it and i didn't like
it
it was it was actually the first time i
had sex i see your finger
like going and then i was like
tried it didn't like it but if you're
into that
okay that's okay all right how do you
define
consent how i define consent
is kind of both parties agreeing to
do something that they both feel
comfortable with i usually like to ask
are you comfortable with this are you
comfortable with this and if it's yes
it's all along the way
great if somewhere in there i'm not
comfortable with like some safe word
like
banana or something then it's just like
an instant stop
consent is an unequivocal desire
at a given moment to engage in any
specified activity with another person
and that includes sex or things that are
not sex
partners
no no i haven't what the heck
i wish that were a thing that'd be dope
no it's usually me that has to
have to do their asking and that's okay
yeah and when they did like
i was kind of like shocked i was like oh
wow that's like you actually care i was
like yes like i do want to have sex
great like thanks for asking have you
ever pressured someone to sleep with you
do you regret it
absolutely not and i would regret it yes
i've never done that that feels
horrible so no i've never done that you
know sex just isn't worth
that to me and that's something that
that the other person would have to
carry with them for the rest of their
lives and and that's something that i'd
have to carry with the rest of my life
it was like me and my girlfriend and you
know i was in the mood and she wasn't so
maybe i was trying to sweet talk her a
little bit like hey come on just
you know that if anything never to
someone never to a stranger never to
anyone that i was just acquaintances
with it was more like a serious
girlfriend or someone that i was
really comfortable with for sure
yeah i would say have um
when i was younger yeah i regret it you
know because
now the way that i look at sex is it's
something special
and you shouldn't be going around and
sleeping with everybody
um it should it should be with someone
that's special to you
and if you ever have to convince someone
to have sex with you then it's not worth
it
i definitely felt pressured from my
friends but i take responsibility for my
actions you know like i am in control of
my body
and it was my making so have you ever
done anything
sexually yes
yes i um i thought i made it pretty
clear to her you know
no i'm i don't want to do i don't want
to do this you know get off of me
so yes i'll answer that bluntly
have you ever felt pressured by peers to
lose your virginity or have a sexual
interaction
yeah more like pressure with like the
world
and culture because sex is such a big
thing especially for like young guys
i was in a fraternity in college coming
into my pledge semester i was the only
virgin
in the fraternity it was almost like an
event every friday saturday every time
we had a party
it was all i could think about like i
couldn't even think about
school most of the time just because all
i was thinking about was like i don't
want to have this label anymore
i was sick of it just the stigma of
being a virgin is like this
we shouldn't feel bad for being a virgin
honestly if i want to be completely
honest i find myself doing it bro
you better have like sex with her or
else like
you're just a like a freaking like loser
bro and that's like
okay but like what if i actually like
the girl and like i don't really want to
have sex yet like
i might have feelings for like i don't
want to take it that fast yet it'll
happen
like relax we know you're horny just
it's fine
it'll happen when it's going to happen
and don't put a lot of pressure on
yourself it's different for everybody
and you should take the time to
understand yourself and be honest with
yourself at the end of the day
[Music]
you